pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux savez vous pourquoi nous
qualifions une personne que l'on trouve
un peu stupide de courge ou de tête de
course
en latin courge se dit que kirby tas à
l'époque les romains utilisaient déjà
des ventouses pour se soigner
c'est certainement l'instrument de
médecine le plus ancien connu à ce jour
qu'ils avaient baptisé ventosa cucurbita
comme cette vente ou servette a inspiré
cette expression a fini par désigner de
manière péjorative une tête vide ventosa
clic urbita fut transformée en cure
bitat kaput littéralement tête de courge
même si l'intérieur d'une courge est
loin d'être vide
pour sûr si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]